experimentará kaliningrado una escasez
de productos
este es el temor de los habitantes de
este enclave ruso encajado entre polonia
y lituania desde este fin de semana el
país báltico ha prohibido el tránsito
por ferrocarril en su territorio de
determinados productos procedentes de
rusia se trata de materiales de
construcción carbón ordenadores y
teléfonos móviles según las autoridades
rusas entre el 40 y el 50 por ciento de
las importaciones podrían estar sujetas
a restricciones hasta 94 los trabajos de
construcción tendrá que detenerse estoy
pensando en la renovación de las
carreteras todo irá peor
yo creo que mucha gente perderá su
trabajo no hay otra opción ni el
gobernador de kaliningrado anunció que
las mercancías restringidas se enviarían
por mar en el plazo de una semana por su
parte el kremlin exige que se levanten
las medidas esta decisión es realmente
inédita es una violación de todo
entendemos que esto se debe a la
decisión de la unión europea de ampliar
las sanciones al tránsito creemos que
esto también es ilegal la situación es
más que grave y requiere un análisis
exhaustivo antes de elaborar medidas
respuestas este análisis en profundidad
se realizará en los próximos días ante
las amenazas rusas del jefe de la
diplomacia de la unión europea acudió al
rescate del gobierno lituano puesto 3
nou blue kate no hay bloqueo el tránsito
de pasajeros y mercancías no sancionadas
continua ascensión
continuos y sueñas not taking lituania
no ha adoptado ninguna restricción
nacional unilateral y solo aplica las
sanciones de la unión europea
union seiu
según las autoridades del enclave el
ministro de asuntos exteriores ruso
convocará al embajador de la unión
europea en moscú el martes